hello everyone and welcome to the Rotten
Tomatoes after-show my name is Mark
Ellis and this is may be my most
anticipated after show I guess of all
time because we get to talk about star
wars episode 9 the rise of Skywalker the
epic conclusion to this saga that has
lasted for longer than I have on this
earth and in many galaxies far far away
I have a great panel joining me here
before we get to them one of that
everybody out there know this is a
spoiler heavy show so we've all seen the
movie we hope you have as well you have
been warned we're talking about
everything in this movie and speaking of
that the movie currently stands at 58%
on the tomato meter and that is with 249
reviews coming in as of this taping so
maybe it's surprising it's not fresh
we're gonna get into all that stuff
right now this actually makes it
currently the second lowest Star Wars
saga film on the tomato meter the
Phantom Menace is 53% let's welcome our
incredible panel here to talk all things
Star Wars Maude Garrett is here Joelle
Monique and last but certainly not least
Scott movie release date man I'm just
going to cross the streams here and say
live long prosper and may the force be
with you Star Trek flavor there and why
not because JJ Abrams has done both
franchises as well I won't take on the
movie whether y'all think it's fresh or
rotten the critics consensus right now
on Rotten Tomatoes Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker suffers from a frustrating
lack of imagination but concludes this
beloved saga with fan focused devotion
Scott manse you hear that what is your
consensus this movie fresh Arad I think
it's very fresh I love the hell out of
it I was extremely entertained while I
was watching the film twice
you know first one was at the premiere
so of course that was exciting washing
it again with you know just my clear
head of these three movies in this new
trilogy I'm gonna say rise of Skywalker
was my favorite of the three okay
favorite of the free I was very very
satisfied and it is fresh I want to talk
about the Kinect too
the with this new trilogy we'll get into
that in a little bit 12 Monique fresher
rotten for you okay because we only have
two options and I don't consider it
fresh I have to say rotten that's a weak
way to get got I'm sorry but that's
where I'm at I don't appreciate the
shelving of basically every major POC
character I thought some of the
conclusions we reached were some more
conclusions we've reached not from the
original trilogy and if we're bringing
balance we should be trying to approach
a new way to bring balance to the force
so I thought that was kind of weird I
will say that it's my second most
favorite beautiful Star Wars movie after
rogue one some of these shots are just
like out of control just breathtakingly
gorgeous but you have to have a story
things have to happen and it's just it's
a lot of weak sauce for me I love fandom
I love showing the fans appreciation and
giving us what we want we have to back
that up with a solid story and that did
not happen in this movie so we got a
fresh we got a rotten and don't worry
about your rotten because there's
actually a book called rotten movies we
love that are not considered fresh Maude
Garrett fresher Ron and I have been
waving storms of abuse for having this
opinion and for that I'm not sorry at
all because I'm sticking to it this
movie to me was fresh JJ Abrams had such
a gargantuan job ahead of him he's not
only completing the trilogy which I
don't think we should ever call this a
trilogy because it was not working
together at all but he was finishing a
saga that lasted over 40 years and I
think that to do that he had to hit a
lot of strokes for me I feel like I
strapped in for a ride and I was
entertained throughout the entire thing
there was so much going on but I felt
the pacing was amazing and I was like
just enraptured in what was going on and
by the end same thing I was like I feel
satisfied and it was just like a bit of
a hug had a bit of a cry and now I'm
just like yeah cool he did the best with
what he had I guess I don't know what I
was witness to that cry but yeah
I mean that's the thing with Star Wars
is it because I mean it's been in my
life since since oh before I was born
and so it's something I get very
emotional whenever I approach one of
these and then when I'm able to separate
myself from the fact that this is just
in my family like the forces I look at
this movie and I say this is fresh for
me - simply because I felt the spirit of
the classic trilogy I loved how fast the
movie moved I loved that we took some
chances with mythology I think that the
connective tissue in bringing this
entire saga - it's a pit conclusion was
worthwhile and again I just I go back to
the word fun I had such a great time
watching this movie and I think it's a
very watchable movie for that purpose
and this is a luxury that we get as Star
Wars fans you know we get to see the
movie early and we're very privileged to
do that yes and then we have to keep our
thoughts very succinct and we can't give
away any spoilers and now we just get to
let all of the kittens out of the bag so
let's get right into these huge spoilers
these huge reveals I mean Rey is a
Palpatine is a path now she does herself
a Skywalker at the end but [ __ ] her
grandpappy is Emperor Palpatine was that
the biggest surprise of the movie to you
mom what do you think of all this first
out as it was revealed really quite soon
and I feel like you know the force away
because we had the mystery box it was
illusion it was like what does it all
mean and then of course with the last
Jedi it was like it means nothing let's
go existential let the past die and it
was like no the past is important but I
like that I got answers really really
quickly there was no more guessing it
was just like bumptious Palpatine boom
this is why she's so angry she's finally
got our identity and she's just sort of
like filled with this I guess you know
it's always the chosen one and destiny
happening here but that rage that she
was fueling which then added so much
more weight behind the relationship with
kylo / Ben and their dynamic which was
in the last Jedi how they spoke in that
connectivity that they had and I loved
that JJ allowed that to grow further in
this movie so that was cool and when we
see Rey really realized her full
Palpatine abilities Joelle and kylos
look I mean because look even if you're
like me you try to avoid as much
speculation as possible we all knew that
there were out rate could be related to
Palpatine and so seeing how early the
movie hints at that very overtly and
then we see her full power I thought
that was that was a pretty stellar part
of the movie
seeing ray use her power was amazing
like this was our first female Jedi in a
Star Wars movie she is way more powerful
than most of the Jedi we seen that's
super cool
Palpatine being her grandpa when did
Palpatine have family the father that
was our parent and if we're looking like
really intently at like Jedi v lor like
the rule of two is now just one all of
the sets are gonna live in just one
person it's that's what's been happening
the whole time should know since leader
what what chaos it makes no sense guys
okay now first of all you said you said
in your opening remark how you didn't
think that there was enough that there
was a story here if anything I feel like
the rise of Skywalker has maybe too much
story because you could feel JJ Abrams
returning its director after the force
awakens he did a major course correction
he's trying to bring it back and yeah it
does I did feel the strain in that sense
but I still enjoy the film
as for us her rate being a Palpatine
when the Empire Strikes Back came out in
May of 1980 and by the way okay y'all
are saying oh you know Star has been
around since you were born I was seven
years old when I saw Star Wars and the
opening weekend May 25th 1977 at the
Eric fairless hills right outside
Philadelphia
I'm sure the hair is a dead giveaway
okay but but I loved how the rise of
Skywalker it felt like a throwback
certainly plot points felt like a
throwback to the best of the Empire
Strikes Back and the best of Return of
the Jedi and the reveal with raping a
Palpatine while not nearly as shocking
as Luke I am your father or no I am your
father I mean nothing will ever top that
yeah in movie history nothing will ever
top that except maybe the end of Planet
of the Apes but that reveal I didn't see
it coming cuz Elvis time I'm thinking
some was right Luke's daughter
I mean is she is she lay his daughter
like I was that's where I was going
because I was like when they hinted at
Rey being a Palpatine so early in the
movie I'm thinking JJ I know what you're
doing right now you're teasing us all
and then she's actually gonna be really
no v1 or somebody else and nope
he's actually his grandpappy and when
you get into the war or she's his
granddaughter I'd say when you get into
the Lord that we just learned about this
it that the Palpatine was able to you
know meet a nice young lady and knock
some boots one night in the mid-south
like but after all of this procreation
madness and then you also had like the
SIDS aaahm be that we're keeping alive
and all these Sethe followers and all
these things the just him to be able to
exist after death a lot of that stuff I
go back to that scene in Revenge of the
Sith where he's talking to Anakin about
you know the the abilities that are
unnatural but also Darth Plagueis the
wise and how he's looking at doing some
experimentation with being able to do
stuff after death or in death or prevent
that from happening and so if that's
Palpatine then how much more did he get
into that and and find ways to be able
to do all this stuff that we saw in rise
of Skywalker okay like it first of all
you call him grandpappy I'm gonna call
him a grandpappy but but you know okay
so wait of joelle you mentioned how I
like work did he have time to have a
family and all this stuff you know when
the Empire Strikes Back came out we
found out that Lou Vader was Luke's
father you know at that time and for
many many many years you're like one did
Vader how the heck could he have had
like a family of course then George
Lucas made the prequels and boy did we
find out not saying that we should have
another series of films about the
Palpatine I'm not suggesting that at all
we have an entire canon full of stories
including about Papa teen this is never
hinted at and to your point about like
this it takes us back to that like I as
a fan of Star Wars I don't want to be
reminded of another film again like I
don't think that going backwards helps
and improve the story or or Shaka's I
wanted that shot I wanted to be slightly
you're not going backwards you're
wrapping it up and your book ending your
book ending things like I don't know if
that did you notice that when the reveal
happened with raping a Palpatine and she
like was like totally freaked out did
you notice that she was backing up like
she was gonna throw herself off the
ledge but she was backing up like she
was like going to do what Luke did when
he found out that Vader was his father
and he just like sacrificed him
but then the Falcon was right there and
she like jumped right on it and she was
saved but that moment was a throwback to
the Empire Strikes Back just like the
whole confrontation with Palpatine was
the fort back time I can like in Back to
the Future 2 and Marty backs off with
this hole it doesn't make sense like who
is Palpatine insidious and how has this
been going on for he has always been the
galaxy's puppet master he has you know I
think that we sort of forget that he
controlled Vader like Vader was his
protege and this whole time he's always
three steps ahead and he's playing
everyone all the time so to think that
he was doing it sort of like after death
that was already like established in
Revenge of the Sith so he knows that we
that was his attitude towards at all for
me it absolutely made sense that Sidious
was still there behind the scenes
working at all because he is basically
if the Empire exists it's because of you
it's something that I can by and look
now do I think that at the start of the
force awakens when JJ sat down to to
create that film was he thinking oh the
last one we're gonna have alpha team I
do not but I also think that I can
understand both either you know praises
or critiques where it does feel like
we're going back and we're using a
character that we already had run his
course but in using that old character I
do like a lot of the new mythology that
we did introduce the Star Wars that we
can build upon with all these different
things that sit there able to do even
after they perish at least we think they
perish somebody who did actually perish
in the movie is Ben yeah I said Ben
didn't say kylo Ren will cut litrenta
too I guess but what a beautiful way for
to redeem a character that I did not
think was redeemable after I saw him put
his laser sword in the Han Solo I was
like okay the one thing that this
trilogy can not do is redeem this guy I
found myself buying into his Redemption
because Leia is is putting herself into
him and putting all the good that she
has left and that's going to take her
life and then we get to see this this
vision of Han Solo talking to his son
and that was the one way that I was like
okay kylo you can come on back and be
Ben again so well how did you take that
yeah
maybe more the more emotional parts a
father-son stuff always liked it in the
face yeah I love that
oh my god when Han Solo camera screen
now
Wow see that's when I love being a fan
go ahead this is the dialogue that he
used to kill his father and being used
at same time to be like I don't know if
I can do this which means like he's
gonna throw his saber away there's a lot
of like really beautiful moments in the
interaction I vocally on this channel
it's like I don't want him to be
redeemed like let it's like again just
change up the story a little bit but it
was maybe my favorite part in story the
whole life I'm not sure if I like how
necessarily the end part of them like
switching life forces back and forth was
filmed the rocking was kind of weird
there were laughs in my theater but I
did I did enjoy the fact that in her
moment of anger she chose to heal and
that to me it was like the first line of
like oh this girl's like on the pass
really be a Jedi what but when you have
that moment of redemption what's the
difference between that and the moment
of redemption
Vader shows the reception is earned I
don't feel like Darth Vader got redeemed
either for what it's worth now yeah III
think redemption is is a process and so
to get it right at the end it never
feels satisfactory to me and this is
just across all movies not specifically
Star Wars but just if you're being
redeemed right at the end by being like
I'm sorry I don't do much I feel like
Ben Witt was young enough and that and
that Redemption scene did hold some
weight for me but again seeing just just
having the surprise I mean you talk
about a spoiler in a movie seeing seeing
Han Solo show up that was that really
meant a lot to me and having him say the
iconic line I know that he said it's
like 30 seconds and service to the
extreme but I bought it hook line and
sinker I loved it you know the thing
about the evolution of the character of
Ben of kylo Ren is I love the arc okay
the this new trilogy is wildly uneven I
you know like you said
think you said we were talking before a
camera that that not a whole lot of
thought went into the Ark of the trilogy
when they wanted to make the force
awakens in 2015 they didn't have it
mapped out and that was something also
that on Rotten Tomatoes Dan Merrill from
screen junkies also said like you could
tell that they really didn't have a
clear plan for this trilogy when they
started out and that has harmed them and
the audience completely and irreparable
but I still I still love the film I
still love that moment and there are
things that we've learned about the
force that we didn't see before like
with ray healing that aliens wound and
then you know her doing the same for Ben
before stealing well I I thought worked
and but then you also had the kiss I
mean a lot of people follow the kiss
what do we think about this smooch so
quiet vocally I haven't enjoyed kylo Ren
as an antagonist throughout this series
when you've put him up against Vader
which is what he's essentially doing
Vader had such graviton which he never
had and I will never forget every single
time I still force awakens in cinemas
when he took his helmet off everyone
laughed and it breaks my heart when
people laugh at him for the wrong reason
but there's a reason behind it this is
the first movie I liked kylo Ren in it
yeah I think that Adam drive I had so
much more to do than be an angry tantrum
throwing brat and just seeing he was an
actor really flex I was like oh my god
I'm gonna just you know what temple I
was like oh he's called me he's going on
a rampage then he goes in I mean that
just his walk it felt like I was walking
with him and I'm walking faster than I
thought I would walk this early in the
movie and I'm like we are really going
to a lot of places here and and we did
say goodbye to the last of the classic
big three Leia as she saved her son in a
way the let's talk about the emotions
behind that goodbye to Leia from it
wrecked me twice it wrecked me when
she's laying down and artoo leans
forward and I'm like oh god and then I
first of all Carrie Fisher was in this
movie a whole lot more than I expected
her to death great I thought she'd maybe
have like a scene that they used maybe
that when they were filming last Jedi or
or force awakens that they just didn't
use and they're just gonna sort of like
seeing around it bite but she was in the
movie a whole lot more than I expected
and I loved the way that it all paid off
you know it was extremely emotional not
only heard that scene not only like you
said with with our two leaning in
because I mean who doesn't love our to
truly know he did not but also I loved
the scene it's a quick flashback scene
that lasted maybe 30 seconds when you
see Luke training Leia how cool is that
how cool give it up mister that was
awesome - well no wait come on wait wait
let me just finish my thought I mean
that scene I thought now there is a
movie okay if you can do a film like
Gemini man where you have this CGI
version of young Will Smith how great
would it be to have maybe like a
webisode of young Luke treat training
young Leia or apparently that's how the
movie was supposed to start now this is
all speculation I don't have much weight
behind it but I did hear that it was
originally going to be a scene two
people training with helmets on back and
forth back and forth someone knocks the
other to the ground and you can see them
lose out in anger a little bit and it
was later on Luke and she was like okay
if I keep training I think I'm gonna tap
into some darkness here light saber -
because I do consider her to be a Jedi I
mean that's how I look at it and I like
that that her her political answer for
why she's not training anymore is
because I feel like I can do more from a
as a politician but now it's explained
she had that vision of things going
really bad and she's like take this
lightsaber get up how high for me you
know it's a somebody who can use it
better than I can because I'm scared of
my own power actually add to that as
well which I think so great because
we're obviously introducing people being
force sensitive and Finan is one of them
and she's you know starting to be able
to connect with other people and he's
like oh my gosh this is something that
I've got he's a general he has a very
very similar storyline to Leia in the
sense where he had a path in front of
him and it was forked he could go down
the line of force training and become
potentially a Jedi or he could be a
schematic officer and do what Leia did
and he's taken up her stead and I
thought that was really cool yeah the
Jedi does not work for me it doesn't
I feel like Leah so grounded is she and
she's been on the battlefield like 17
like I feel like she would find a
different way to use her force powers
we've have the expanded universe a to
keep going to it but that's where my
fandom originates from its from the
expanded universe back in the Dark Ages
movies to debate about we had to go into
the animated shows when those came out
and blessed us and fixed Clone Wars like
there's so many great force bend you
from the rebels I I think she would have
found a way to quietly use her force
powers and to say that she would have
been too tempted by the dark side for me
like lay up yeah Golden Queen couldn't
have handled it there's a lot that
doesn't work for me that her lightsaber
feels like a cash grab and when you bury
it it doesn't feel that doesn't feel
like Leia to me and I don't have that
resonance with her lightsaber as being a
part of who she is and so it doesn't
work for me in the same way that Finn
being force sensitive and they're not
ever getting to outwardly address it
really bummed me out I was like we have
like the first first but guy other than
mace windu to be on the big screen with
it she's just it's just a feeling about
what's let's move into that that new big
three that we're talking about with Finn
because Finn and Poe and Rey and just
and then their moments or maybe lack
thereof what what I liked about what
this movie was doing is that it did get
to unite them for the most part and they
get split off from time to time but I
like seeing the big three of them
on-screen together maybe at the
sacrifice of some of their individual
storylines okay I'm glad you brought
that up because one of the things that
I've really loved about the rise of
Skywalker was seeing the three of them
together I would like to have seen Rose
be a part of that because she certainly
deserved to be Kelly Marie Tran but to
see Oscar Isaac John boyega and Daisy
Ridley together was very very rewarding
because I thought the chemistry between
the three of them was terrific love
delight I mean the fact that Poe and Ray
were like bickering like that was sort
of new to see on screen you're like oh
it's getting better I know we'll say
with the last Jedi one of its faults was
the fact that they split rey and finn up
the whole movie because these two
genuinely love each other in real life
their chemistry is amazing so to see
them just be separated
they actually confess in an interview
that I had with them that was the
hardest part about that second movie for
them that they weren't in scenes
together do it like this this movie a
lot of the jokes this movie I thought it
landed because of the interaction of the
big three Finn Poe ray and then
Joelle you talk about Ray's arc did you
find that to be satisfying that where
she started from from force awakens as
the scavenger and then she ends up
briefly being a Palpatine before it
being like now let's change the name on
my ID this guy Walker yes what I really
liked about Ray's journey I thought the
way that she was first confronted by her
friends to be like listen this alone
business is not to me the when star wars
the best is when we're in a group
fighting together that's across all
platforms and so I love that they're
like where are you going like no we're
coming with we're getting on the ship
we're gonna fight together all of that
really works for me
I like oh god I love that she has a
yellow saber at the end yeah like if you
get you don't know the Knights who guard
the Jedi Temple had yellow sabers they
are meant to represent knowledge and
basicly Jedi's who are more like
knowledge seekers than fighters and it
it's so beautiful to be like listen
she's choosing she don't even fight no
more if hopefully she's brought balance
to the universe and we're in a good
place and so she can go off from that
all of that really works for me or are
you talking about Palpatine so we don't
have to go in to be fair I think that
that yellow gold savor the Rey has I
think that's selling more lightsabers
then then Ben way as well I think that's
that that's the money making lightsaber
for me any that's what I'm buying
I've loved Ray's journey and I got to
tell you I thought Daisy Ridley's
performance and rise of Skywalker was
superb I thought she crushed it I
thought she just gave such a satisfying
third act to the development of our
character you know it's such a big
massive production like a Star Wars film
such so many characters and visual
effects and all that stuff that her
performance is she is the the Luke
Skywalker of this trilogy you know she
is the the center she is that the I
guess that the one sort of bolt that
holds the whole machine together Daisy
Ridley was just phenomenal I thought she
was terrific in this movie to go a
little bit more on that I feel like the
fight scenes obviously been or kylo and
right
keep fighting together because there's a
lot of sexual chemistry but also they're
really angry and she's just fueled by
anger because she knows she's got some
of the dark side in her but what I
really loved in this is the last Jedi
and in this movie as well when they stop
fighting each other and they team up
together and those lightsaber sequences
that you have they're fantastic what I
really loved as well I'm there's so much
Mary Sue talked with Rey which I hope we
can put to bed already but I mean I like
the opposite when they're completely
overpowered and when they're fighting
over that ship and then using the force
together I'm like bring on all the false
powers bring on everything when she used
her Jedi Mind Tricks I was like yes we
needed more of that I want to see these
two I wanted to see kylo and Rey so
overpowered because that's what
Dragonball Z is like to a team to really
really powerful strong people fighting
to Vegeta and Goku yeah I mean my
favorite scene in the last Jedi was when
Rey and kylo or best so Scott yes you
brought up before the Star Wars is
celebrated not just for our big three
for our core oh these are the people
that are gonna be the stars of the movie
it's all these great supporting
characters and we got so many of them in
rise of Skywalker we got to see old
faces return we got to introduce some
new characters who did you like who did
you want to see more from who got who
got sidelined to you well I definitely
think that that Rose got sidelined I
thought you know Keller Marie Trent she
was a she was a big heart of the last
Jedi and they should just for her to
sort of stay back stay behind seemed a
bit flat right it seemed contrived she
could have been at plenty I'm sure
should have been it should have been it
should have been a course head not a
trio she should have been on that ride I
don't know why she wasn't and for her to
stay behind like that was the most
glaring one to me is that Finn and Rose
seem to be building something in the
last Jedi that now they're just kind of
patting each other's back the I thought
he was in love with pilot one stage and
it's like well they are not gay and it
was very known here here's a woman to
make sure
and really loved each other and that's
what he wanted to confess because that's
what you do when you think you're gonna
die you confess your feelings after that
I thought did not
I forget the character's name but after
his oscar-nominated performance and can
you ever forgive me
Richard II grant I thought he was
miscast I was thinking he was the spy
until we find out that domhnall gleeson
spy that was a fun little reveal yeah
behind it we didn't need hugs running
around and joining the resistance but it
was just kind of fun I like that then he
says five he's like I don't care about
you I just really hate this other guy I
hate my co-workers I'm sure I made into
that beat into that comment I don't want
you to win I just don't want kylo Ren
guy I don't want you to I I just don't
want kylo Ren to win yeah read it to
that way you will read in time reading
will okay I'm reading some of it some of
your favorite supporting characters who
shown who did not get the chance to
shine he would have liked Janna's one
scene where she meets Finn and they're
discovering their past was so electric
love tonight instantly needed more
that's what I hope they're setting up at
the end with Lando talking to her was
because my okay so when Lana says let's
find out who you are I'm like I think
he's being a good guy it might just be
Lando be Atlanta okay please don't be
your dad because that's racist you can't
the two you white people and their be
related let's not do that
but I was like is he gonna get on earth
that's a land only he is connected
throughout the universe maybe I could
have used a lot more land oh I feel like
Lando is very much just sort of giving
like and yet he got MVP for me that's
maybe my favorite part to re-watch with
with the fans when I go to my many
screenings of this movie that are yet to
come is the scene where pose given up
all hope and he's turned into maverick
at the end of Top Gun where he's just
kind of in a dead spin you just can't
get it together and then all of a sudden
we hear that classic score and it's a
little perfect it's a little convenient
the movies not perfect but that scene
Alando showing up and just having all
these ships fly he
Ledo has a deep-space rolodex debbie
downer right now but how did you seal
the endings of both Captain Marvel and
endgame and just put them at the end of
the Star Wars to get the rise sequence
that is straight from Captain Marvel
including memory stacking - to the
here's all of our heroes at one point
including all of the Force Coast it was
a lot I still think my biggest problem
with this version of Star Wars and we
recount the whole trilogy is the lack of
the ability to surprise me I think what
made the original Star Wars trilogy so
successful was everything like how are
they doing this how do they do that
opening shot how that's cruel I've never
seen anything like that oh my gosh he's
Luke's father maybe huh and I you get so
few of those moments across all three
movies it's hard to think we were more
back then - I think we were all just
babes in the woods just like look at
these movies and look at all this and
now we just live in a culture where
everything is just so broken down when
when a movie is being filmed when it's
like oh there's a cover over spaceship
what does that mean and you know we
can't we just don't live in a world we
can just kind of sit back and be
surprised really quick Damon Lindelof
made a really good point he's the he did
Watchmen recently he was a showrunner on
that he said you came no longer surprise
people in a whodunit because the
internet will be too far ahead we know
the science we know how to break it down
and we're gonna get there he's like you
have to try to understand why people bad
we got thing why are they doing that and
I feel like more of that maybe would
have bolstered Star Wars for me that's
particularly like why is rey doing the
thing she's doing as opposed to like
she's just on a very straight line
mission and who is she and we every
major fan theory is something we've
already seen predicted on the Internet
in a bold way it's and that's a tough
way to be a fan is just to ingest all
the stuff and then go in and try to shed
all those expectations right before the
movie starts one of my favorite things
about Star Wars has been how since the
movie came out back in 77 was Scott was
a was a very very tiny child is that
they used the droids to sell these
movies and I thought c-3po and r2d2 and
and now the bb-8 and do I thought they
were so good I thought they were
hilarious I thought they had great
moments Babu Frick
favorite character was and it's mommy
frequently that scene is a nice cute
thing I've ever seen I want him to be my
little grandfather that fixes things the
whole time beautiful humor oh that whole
thing was absolute and I do like Babu I
like Zuri as well just in her very
limited screen time I thought her and
polite like had something really special
on screen and again that's like the the
Johno Lando thing where it's like I
that's that's a novelization maybe I
won't read about a listen to it on an
audiobook Scott you know you know the
thing is what look you know I've had
some more time to process and still win
this and really think about about so we
have Star Wars the rise of Skywalker or
as I've sort of been thinking about it
you know Star Wars endgame so you could
have this movie that closes out a 9
chapter saga or 11 if you include solo
and rogue one which I loved and then you
have like look at Avengers ain't game
which closed out at 22 film saga now
comparing apples to apples in terms of
last movies I think that a venture st.
game is a is a much better made film and
does a much better job of closing
everything out like I loved Avengers end
game it was a guy here install a like
the Star Wars the the saga as we now
have come to know it it's been a roller
coaster and there have been highs there
have been lows and that's been a great
topic to the bane about and I feel like
you know JJ Abrams when he did okay just
go with me on this when he did the first
Star Trek movie in 2009 and he set
everything up
that was his force awakens the way he
set up this new trilogy when he did Star
Trek into darkness
he tried so hard to throw everything
into star trek into darkness including
the kitchen sink and he threw up he
threw so much Star Trek fan service into
that film that it was a detriment to the
movie but overall I liked Star Trek into
darkness
and overall I had the same sort of
issues with the rise of Skywalker I
thought he tried too hard to please the
fans and it does fall back on Canon a
little too much but I loved that stuff
and just a just like I loved Star Trek
into darkness flaws and all I loved the
rise of Skywalker flaws in all let me
let me ask you all because we do want to
talk about the elephant in the room as
far as the connectivity
I heard a lot of people who I respect
say that they feel like this movie was
just you know it kind of trying on
purpose to refute a lot of what the last
Jedi did I can I can see through that
lens but I do not believe that a lot of
these scenes that people are saying like
when Luke catches the lightsaber in this
one and he says that Jenna never throws
his weapon away I do not see that as
digging here's why is because if Luke
had thrown his lightsaber away at the
end of the last Jedi that's a dig he
throws it away beginning of the last
Jedi then Luke goes on this one last
emotional spiritual journey where he
progresses as a person and so by the end
of the last Jedi he is no longer the
same grizzled old hermit who throws a
light saber Wood said I was wrong yes I
was wrong I admit that we're wrong
sometimes I don't I'm uncomfortable with
people putting thoughts or words into
either of the directors mouths hearing
like oh this for sure was a dig now I
can tell you the fan I was like oh
really yeah
felt like a dig but I&C destroying kylo
ren's mask in the last Jedi as a dig but
some people took it that way the line of
dialogue that was very very clear to me
was let the past die mm-hmm and like I
said a few times
popping up very recently about you know
fanservice is not good for fandom that
was out of context a little bit though
in that interview he may not be saying
it specifically about star I just want
to clear that yeah I don't think he was
saying that about JJ that's particular
by but I do think that he wanted to
challenge fandoms yeah and the best
thing to do is to challenge these people
and he did that and I loved him for it
so joint point I think because we're
able to interpret it this way it just
goes to show how not cohesive these
films are and I think that because
there's not a cohesive thought process
it's hard for fans to come see because
we wound up liking different things like
there's so much in the last job I craved
the the way they interacted with just
the normal people I was enthralled broom
boy is everything to me I know it's very
divisive not everybody likes him but to
me
broom boy is what Star Wars fandom is
about and so when we get the explosions
like don't remember what plan
when they decide to blow well playing it
through they blow up no smoothly
there's before that we seems like the
stormtroopers going on raids the Knights
of Ren are in time we did nothing the
people what how are the people they're
affected them what are they doing to try
to protect themselves it's like these
little intricate moments that create
community that really like weeped out of
last Jedi for me they're completely
missing it wasn't in there as much as
the rise of Skywalker but on that on on
that planet you know I did feel a little
bit of like World War two
I felt like a very Nazi kind of presence
in on that planet when we're you know
we're kind of running around and trying
to hide from this regime that's trying
to take over and so I I do see a little
bit of those themes but you know I I
will be the first one to admit that
connectivity was not quite there with
this new trilogy having said that I
think that you can be a fan of the last
Jedi and you can be a fan hated the last
Jedi he's gonna love this movie and I'm
like nah that's not entirely true either
but I do love them for very very
different and distinct reasons you know
I loved that the last Jedi was
risk-taking and it just challenged the
audiences and spun it on its head a
little bit and yeah it's like people
going but none of this made sense and
the plot is completely flawed and I'm
like you're right but I had the best
time watching it that's that's the code
of right there Amoy yeah I mean yeah
there's some flaws to this this entire
late latest trilogy but I still enjoyed
it I felt I love being a Star Wars fan I
love Star Wars and even though I don't
like the prequels I still love Star Wars
yeah I'm kind of the same way but at
least in the previous I can find moments
that I like let's all take a moment this
I hate movies cost what's the moment
that you saw it like for me it's it's I
love the celebration I love Chewie
getting a medal I thought that was so
great but Mons gave it to him and when
we pan out of that celebration shot we
see our big three celebrate then we also
see Chewie r2d2 and c3po all having
their nice little quiet moan to
themselves that mental the more than I
thought it would that's been and then
closing up yes seeing best been seeing
Endor having some justice for a walks
out there and then having
that final shot be the two sons as soon
as we went to Tatooine I'm just saying
JJ please close that with two sons got
the two sons got rey and bb-8 the way
that i thought it should be let's
quickly give a moment that we can really
take from this movie good or bad i'll be
doing about the whole time
rey calling leia master broke me i was
ill-prepared even though I don't
necessarily see her as a Jedi the
boomer and all he's my favorite Jedi and
like ladies like Jedi Master holy cow
amazing the lights be jumping was
incredible more of that is invented they
take something we're familiar with and
pushes its boundaries it was dangerous
and exciting and then because I felt
such a nice character touch when poems
then come back with his ship and raise
like what have you done to my [ __ ] like
it's her ship now I'm like the batons
philippe it was a fun interactive all of
that energy seeing those guys together
and and making it more of a team effort
it's really those are the parts of the
movie that works best for Scott your
moment my mom well of course they're you
know at the very end of the film when
she says you know I my name is Skywalker
and you see her with the two sons I mean
it just
I felt satisfied I felt very emotional
at that moment but my favorite scene in
the film was actually the lightsaber
battle between ray and Ben over the
destroyed Death Star was beautiful okay
and and the reason I loved that scene
was because it threw back to what I
thought was one of the better moments of
the of the prequel trilogy was when
obi-wan and Anakin were fighting over
the lava yeah so you have this
lightsaber battle over crashing waves
over this destroy Death Star and they're
really going at it all that the elements
that doesn't matter they're just going
at it you know fight each other and have
reminded me of that might saber battle
over the crashing lava flows that Anakin
had been were Kenobi we're fighting over
in revenge of this interesting yin and
yang of natural elements really you know
but there's a lot of yin and yang there
are a lot of Farrah back moments to the
best moments of the original trilogy and
also the prequel trilogy because there
were a few like to point out mark and
and I love that this movie brings it all
to a close
I mean my my tweak when I walked out of
the cinema was saying within the first
20 minutes I realized that this was the
best movie of the trilogy which is why I
got so much hate online I said the same
thing but it's this thing where I
realize like that quickly that we are on
the desert planet it feels like an
Indiana Jones kind of adventure
happening at the moment then you've got
this new creature and she's healing it
and I was just so inundated with all of
this great stuff that and then they
chewy getting kid not fight so that for
me that first like chunk of the film I
was just like buckle up
I was like yeah I was so in so that for
me it was just like we're on a path
aside and something I'm excited about on
that on my next rewatch is trying to
hear how many Jedi voices I can pick out
in there because when they create
Freddie Prinze jr. Ashley Eckstine in
the credits and it's like oh there's a
lot of Jedi second time I said I
definitely heard mace I heard Hayden I
heard it was it was really cool where
does this movie rank in your your
favorite Star Wars films of all time
what is your favorite Star Wars film and
what does that do to the rise of
Skywalker where are we on the latter
mods start with you favorites dust I was
maybe of all time is not the best Star
Wars movie of all time I will have you
know for me it was Return of the Jedi
because it was the first movie that I
saw in cinema and they digitally
mastered it and that for me seeing it on
the big screen and convincing friends
that had never seen any Star Wars ever
to watch it with me was like my moment
go ahead and do that again it's my
favorite Star Wars film not the best in
this case if we are going to use it in
the trilogy umbrella which is not a true
leader you just three movies that happen
to run alongside each other and be named
Stefan even though it is my favorite of
those three okay but then it goes last
Jedi and then force awakens because I
thought that was just a boring maybe Joe
well yeah I think my favorites are just
Empire Strikes Back as far as everything
lighting editing shooting it's beautiful
where does this one rank I think if I
had to choose right now I'd say Empire
Strikes Back
rogue one last Jedi and then this movie
um there's so much to like but I I think
we got off track of what it means to be
a Jedi and a Sith which is really
important as you're wrapping up
franchise it's hard to hold it above
those but from a filmmaking perspective
like we're looking at just as a film
it's a solidly made film as we're
looking at a Star Wars film for me it's
got a lot of caveats Scott okay I'm so
glad you asked this question Marcus why
I'm here like high five to you on Return
of the Jedi that's such a beautiful
moment that you described and high five
to you on the Empire Strikes Back which
is not only the greatest Star Wars movie
of them all but it is one of the
greatest movies ever made period it is I
say the Empire Strikes Back is the
Citizen Kane of Star Wars movies so in
terms of like just I I watch The Empire
Strikes Back all the time especially now
that I have Disney plus I watch it all
the time it's like on in the background
while I'm doing other things it's like
having a best buddy in the room and it
just it's just a great movie period one
of the greatest movies ever made in
terms of the rankings obviously the
Empire Strikes Back is first then this
movie that is called star wars which is
now known as a new hope my third
favorite is rogue one I freaking love
the hell out of rogue one I was so every
time I watch that movie I can't wait to
watch a new hope and just they snap
together like Lego number four all my
list is the rise of Skywalker yeah I'm a
dumb a Jedi boy through and through so I
love seeing a movie where we win at the
end we did we lost a couple pilots in an
Ewok we'll get over it and with this
movie I think this is really on a par
with force awakens for me so I put all
three in this new trilogy above the
three prequels and then where they rank
I'm still kind of letting that settle my
head but rise with Skywalker I thought
it was it was a great ride I had so much
fun with it and it brought back all the
Star Wars feels that has been instilled
in me by my my incredible family since
the day I walked on this planet and I
was thankful for a nice closing saga
that maybe it gave me a lot of questions
maybe more questions an answer but it
also it gave me the emotional closure
that I wanted from these nine movies and
now I feel like I graduated and I guess
I got to get a job where we go I know
where we go and that is
on a little break because this is the
last aftershow of 2019 we'll be back in
2020 with a whole lot more in store for
you so go ahead subscribe to the Rotten
Tomatoes youtube channel right now hit
that Bell will give you an alert every
time we have a new after-show and keep
checking that tomato meter at
rottentomatoes.com like I said as of
this taping we have 58 percent for the
rise of Skywalker the experts who are
who study the tomato meter say that it
could get too fresh but it's not going
to deviate that much from where it is
now with 249 reviews currently so in the
audience we are gonna get into all that
as the week's progress for all the rise
of Skywalker updates you can handle goto
rottentomatoes.com
I want to thank all my panelists who
joined me this year on the after show
and especially my panels who showed up
to talk Star Wars with me in front of a
very forgiving audience out there
Scott mance Joelle Monique and Maude
Garrett for the whole team here our
incredible crew everyone we hope you
have a great holiday season and safely
enjoy the rise of Skywalker and hanging
out wherever you may be in the galaxy
with you and yours I'm Mark Ellis and
we'll see you next year
[Music]